so let me give you three principles on
how to do all questions that relate to
Barrett number one read carefully now
read carefully I say this is about all
kinds of questions we've seen for
example in all of the financial stuff
the woods make big differences right
like tiny little words in bearings the
most important words to look up for are
two men from to and from it's really
smoothly because conjunction words like
please they slip underneath your radar
but if you say for example mistake one
for the other
you literally reverse the question like
you're asking the opposite thing if I
say to you from A to B right and like
ask for a barrier okay if we put a
somewhere and then we put B somewhere if
you put a diagram you've got some dots
on there what could go under here to
know which angle I'm trying to work out
I didn't want to give me some
suggestions
the first thing I'm going to do it this
actually is bleeding into the next point
so I might is all right now draw the
diagrams and big diagrams so I'm drawing
a diagram now to try and explain how to
carefully read this the first thing I'm
going to put on is um compass roses
right don't talk too many but enough to
understand what's going on here I really
do have that one on the a like that from
A to B where's the barrier which angle
is that how would you describe it angle
very good
so between north and this one here
aren't so there is where I could find
the Bury okay and whatever the angle is
like say this 35 degrees I might say it
0 35 truth there's my very naturally if
I reverse the words if I say to a from B
the points are still in the same order
but you've changed it completely where
am I now if I say to a from B okay yeah
so I'm gonna have to add a compass rose
over here now like so where's the
bearing what angle I'm juicing this
times good so it's gonna be a reflex
angle again it's from north and this
time it's gonna go all the way around
and then whatever that is okay now it's
worth pointing up these angles are
related to each other they're not like
randomly separated what's the
relationship between this angle and that
one look at Nick what you reckon you
some now this is tricky right but this
is what I focus you know can you use
some words because we've all kind of
like it's the thing with I don't know
really want
how would you explain it it is out of
230 what do you mean by out of 270 so
this is what I just said everyone's on
the same page if we were all the way
around from north or whether back to the
beginning that's 360 we haven't gone
that far have we so you're thinking
about being in this quarter is that what
you're talking about
yeah okay so it is somewhere in there
not 270 though like where would 270 be
actually but though true marry 200
series has a compass bearing what's the
copper spray that goes with that it's
West isn't it there it is okay
so it's not exactly West clearly can you
see because I've got North here at North
here they're both north so they're both
parallel lines right do you remember and
this is why I did them together when
we're doing angles of elevation and
depression again you've got these
parallel lines so what does that mean
have a look what angles are related here
very good
I've got alternate angles the first one
I said this one here right is
alternative just gonna make this compass
rose a bit we've done its alternate to
this angle do you see that just so that
we mark them the same let's call this
one feet up and call this one Athena as
well okay so they alternate they're the
same angle if you found this angle maybe
part two of this question years now can
you tell me this Barry okay you can see
it's the same angle plus one 180 is the
extra bit right so if I said for example
if theta was 35 degrees so that's my
answer to the first one then the answer
to the second one will be that plus
hundred eighty two hundred and fifty
that make sense so clearly completely
different numbers and it's based on
whether you read carefully or not okay
hopefully I've also demonstrated the
importance of drawing the diagram even
when they give you a diagram it's really
important that you for example either
drawn to the diagram they give you
that's one the reasons why we give you
any day or they don't give you one you
had
to draw one Nick okay you gotta be super
super careful in terms of like what did
we do for Part B I added so I got 215
okay now you can imagine even just
looking at this question it's very easy
to mix up adding and subtracting angles
the angle you would subtract would be
this one you see that this one of them
right that's obviously gonna be a
different size just be careful make sure
you know what angle you're calculating
this would be 55 270 takeaway 55 still
the same size so just be watchful what
are you adding
what are you subtracting where are the
angles you're talking about which is why
this message ah last question last point
piranha is reread the question when you
enter okay so this is just making sure
you cap things off you start off by
reading the question so you know what
they're asking but when you think you
have a data go back to the question one
more time
are you actually answering what they're
after or are you giving them an angle
which is like on the way but it's short
you've got to add something to it uh
subtract or you've got to explain okay
how far you gonna go not with the Angels
okay so these are my three principles
that are used all the time